i am a terrible person i'm a horrible
human being
[Laughter]
i left you guys on an insane cliffhanger
the last time we did this i really did i
i am not sorry
sorry not sorry robcor
because i'm gonna do it again so here's
the thing guys here's the thing
so in the last video we basically ended
with the viltrumite war essentially kind
of done for the most part like the the
vulture mites themselves had just
basically been crushed right i mean
these guys had just been crushed in the
worst way and then in turn we then had
like the viltromites taking off right
basically fleeing and then taking off to
earth right mark was the one to figure
out that's what was gonna happen now at
this point we pick up with earth right
the pentagon and literally like thrag
the leader of the viltrumide empire had
and really him and the other vulture
might have basically conquered
everything right like they killed
everyone like they killed everybody i
mean you got cecil begging for his life
right saying like we can coexist
everything will be fine right thrag pops
his head like a grape i mean just
right his head just pops right off his
shoulders and i mean like like the
immortal the whole nine yards right like
duplicate adam eve they're all dead
right every single one of them just
killed and then mark wakes up right and
it's not even really a dream sequence so
much as just mark's imagination on
what's happening on earth mark's
absolutely horrified about about what's
happening there because the viltrumites
as we've seen these guys take no
prisoners man like when the viltrumites
have it for you they're coming man these
guys are coming for you and that's just
the way it is and and the reality is
mark and nolan are really the two most
powerful beings on earth and they
couldn't even put a dent in thrack what
possible hope could any of these other
characters have right adam eve duplicate
whatever i mean arguably adam eve is the
most powerful being in the entirety of
the invincible universe but she hasn't
reached the full totality of what she
can do she can alter matter on the
molecular structure but one it still
takes a pretty large toll on her so it
really exhausts her and two she can only
really do it on relatively small scales
right we haven't seen her do it on
gigantic scales facing off against huge
numbers of enemies she hasn't really
reached that point yet especially
enemies as powerful as the villager
mites and this is kind of the common
theme among basically everybody in the
coalition of worlds at least all the
major players mark's struggling in the
worst way right because his imagination
just goes towards the death and
destruction of everybody that he knows
nolan while he doesn't necessarily seem
to be letting it on he's struggling in
the exact same way but in his mind he
has to be there for his son because who
else is going to be right i mean there's
nobody else here his like mark's mom
debbie she's not here right oliver is
probably waking up right there's not a
whole lot that they can do here and so
literally nolan just kind of has to tell
mark like you got to calm down you got
to relax now a lot of this is coming
from a place where nolan's dealt with
this time and time again right either it
was on earth for the fear of the
viltrumites coming there it was on the
other world that he went to where the
viltromites literally did show up but
nolan's entire life has been mired in
death and destruction so while i
wouldn't necessarily say this is
business as usual what i will say is
it's not new to him right so he kind of
knows how to cope with these things but
even for nolan to a degree this is new
territory but when he was on earth he
met debbie he fell in love he had a son
so even then he still has a lot to lose
but his experience is what really shines
through here his uh his wisdom right
really kind of comes through in these
instances the same thing happens with
alan the alien right where like his
wife's like well the movers aren't going
to be here for 20 minutes you know
something we can knock boots if you're
interested ellen the alien is struggling
as well right i mean it's the same thing
everybody's struggling because everybody
has kind of come to care about each
other in a way right when you're
involved in a major conflict like this
and i've never served in the military so
i can't speak to that but i have to
imagine that in that kind of a situation
when your life is on the line right you
look to the person next to you and you
know that they have your back there's a
kind of camaraderie and a sort of
brotherhood that forms there among these
people and that's what's happened here
right these guys have fought and some of
them have almost died are members of
their group that they've become friends
with who have died right and so in the
revelation that their lives were on the
line any one of them can perish and they
have to look to the person next to them
as a person that will do what they can
to keep them alive in the same way that
they'll do what they can to keep the
other person alive a camaraderie forms
there right a family relationship
dynamic forms there and that's why alan
the alien's not just like yeah man that
sucks for earth good thing i don't live
there right we're just kind of like yeah
man this is terrible
i'm really really worried about what'll
happen if mark and nolan get back to
their home world and find it's been
completely obliterated right so again
just kind of these struggles these
things that they're enduring that
they're kind of going going through and
mark can't really seem to help himself
now again one part of this is just youth
and inexperience the other part of this
is because mark has people he cares
about so his imagination just kind of
deviating to the worst possible
situation it's something that he just
can't help and so ultimately a voice
kind of comes on right the pilots who
you know what have you and say like
we'll be arriving in earth's orbit
shortly take your positions mark
immediately leaves right because he can
survive in the vacuum of space by
holding his breath and he'll he'll
arrive on earth long before his breath
runs out this guy bee lines it towards
his planet right just bolts towards
earth and when he gets there he's
expecting to see death destruction the
end of all things when he arrives there
everything's fine there's no death
there's no destruction the guardians of
the globe are not scattered to the four
winds right there it's not like that
instead he's just kind of okay cool
they're not here they're not here right
because one of the things that nolan
kept telling mark is there's no way that
we know for sure they're heading to
earth there's a good chance they are not
gonna lie to you son but we don't know
exactly if that's really what's
happening as mark's making his way
through there he's like no cool
everything's fine they're not here
they're not here we don't have to worry
about things
interthrag right this guy's like no we
are very much here we very much are here
on your world right your your suspicion
that we were coming to earth is 100
accurate and mark immediately lashes out
right an emotional state immediately
lashes out and attacks throughout nolan
tries to hold him back like look no no
that's not gonna happen son right
because mark's like i killed conquest
i'll find a way to kill you let me tell
you something mark like killing conquest
that's cool and everything and it's nice
this guy's on a whole different level
right this is this this guy is on a
whole different level right i mean mark
defeating conquest whatever man conquest
was afraid of this guy if that gives you
any indication of freddie mercury's
power right this guy is is nothing to be
nothing to be messed with right and then
so ultimately what what freddie mercury
actually does is he stops mark right
instead of killing him because we know
that he doesn't want to kill mark he
doesn't want to kill nolan it's one of
the things we saw at the end of the last
video that they need them he like throws
them to the side and says look you know
if you believe you can kill me that's
fine and by some chance you happen to
injure me just know i'm not here alone
the rest of my army is here as well and
they'll destroy this world and that's
when he says like i am here because i
want to talk right if you want to fight
we can fight and i promise it will not
end well for you right this fight will
be over before it even starts i was
going easy on you earlier i can i can
tear you limb from limb in a matter of
seconds so either we can talk or we can
fight which one is it and also they're
kind of like all right cool let's talk
now this is one of the most interesting
developments in any comic book story
that i think i've ever read right
remember the viltromites have been
billed as this race right just like a
race of supermen basically that are evil
like conquering the universe that kind
of a thing what freddie mercury says is
there's only 37 of us left that's it
when those 37 of us are gone our race is
extinct that's it like 37 members of the
viltromites are what separate us from
continued survival to extinction and so
he says like you know at the end of the
day like i could destroy this world
right now and it would be a fair and
just response to what you did right
destroying the viltrumite world he says
but i don't want that if this war
continues on this is not a war that we
can survive right sure we'll lay waste
to earth and everybody on earth will die
but so will our race and in reality the
glory of the viltrumide empire is far
more significant than some small little
mud ball on a backwater solar system
right like we don't care about that like
what we care about is continuing to
survive so he says like you took our
world from us we're going to take your
world from you and the response of mark
and nolan and really mark himself is
more like total disgust like wait so
what are you gonna are you gonna like
allow humanity to evacuate are you going
to ask us to literally pack up and leave
our planet so we can and try to find
another one that we can live on so you
can have this one that's not going to
happen right and ultimately like like
freddie mercury is like we're already
here right and we don't want to leave
but just something that you need to
understand here you couldn't make us
leave if you wanted to try with all your
might there's nothing you could do to
make us leave here he's like so here's
what i propose we will live among your
people right we look just like humans
they will never notice the difference
between us and anybody else right unless
we perform some insane feat of strength
or fly or whatever it is but he's like
we will stay hidden we'll get regular
jobs and we will live in secret among
everybody on this world and no one will
know that we are here here's what i ask
we'll blend in we will intermingle and
we will interbreed we will have children
with humanity and when the time is right
then we'll conquer your world
so it's basically let's put this war on
hold for right now so we can muster our
forces and kill you later right now the
whole response here is like the whole
response of mark is like what you know
and ultimately like like the response of
thragger of freddie mercury is like it's
the only way to survive right we will
restore our ranks over the course of
thousands of years he says human dna has
been proven to make near-perfect hybrids
the closest thing we have to
pure-blooded viltrumites our children
and our children's children will join
our ranks their children will have
children and our ranks will swell with
the infusion of human dna you will allow
us time to restore our numbers to
rebuild our empire though the two of you
were responsible for the destruction of
our home world you will provide us with
our ultimate salvation the two of you
represent the future of our people what
we will become what we must become in
order to survive this is how things must
be and he says i will have your answer
now please do not make me destroy what
would be our last hope for survival this
is a big deal because it's basically
like it's all or nothing folks if you
say yes then we'll destroy you at a
future point in time you can do what you
can to try to make more powerful people
and maybe somebody later on down the
line and your genetic structure will be
more capable but like we're gonna either
we're gonna stay here and rebuild our
ranks or we're gonna wipe out this whole
world and we'll die in the process and
that's fine right we'll take that death
if it means destroying all of you in the
process right so ultimately like the
whole response of market is wait so
you're proposing you're what you're
telling me freddie mercury is you want
to be able to live on our world so you
can become stronger and you want you
want me to agree like how can i possibly
agree to that and he's like tomorrow's
not today right today is not tomorrow
worry about that tomorrow right worry
about that later what you have right now
mark is a choice to make the choice that
you can make is to allow us to live here
and to agree to my terms we'll be in
secret but we'll swallow our ranks and
we'll destroy you at a future point in
time or we'll destroy you all right now
which one is it going to be and so
ultimately like nolan like mark freaks
out mark's like this is the most
ridiculous thing ever and then nolan's
like no right and mark like this is one
of those times you're gonna have to say
yes this is one of those times when
you're not going to want to but you're
going to have to and where mark is so
emotional and mark is so torn up and is
like no like i don't want to have
anything to do with that he thinks back
to what the world will look like if the
viltrumites have free reign because 37
viltromites against two one of which is
a human hybrid and hasn't reached its
full potential yet the other one has
been alive for thousands of years and is
still nowhere near close to powerful
enough to take out one emperor let alone
anybody in his royal guard uh there is
the only thing that mark can do here is
say yes and that's what mark does mark
agrees to the terms of freddie mercury
and says yes fine you guys can stay here
on our world you can interbreed
intermingle whatever it is that you need
to do mark ultimately acquiesces to the
emperor of the viltromite empire with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace